how do you feel when you see these kind
of headlines oh i think it's awful and i
talk about this precise point in my book
ultimately the establishment are going
to be hostile towards bitcoin because
they can't control it bitcoin is it is
decentralized by nature it's censorship
resistant and of course there's no ceo
that can control it this means if we
were to live on this bitcoin standard
where people are trading goods and
services in bitcoin then it's actually
going to dismantle the current system as
we know it and why would they allow that
they obviously wouldn't because those
who control the money control everything
and right now those who do control the
money are having a great time the system
that we have is serving those at the top
the most they can print as much money as
they like they can increase taxes to
help pay for the debasement of the
currency so ultimately why would they
want to change a system which is serving
them so well right
well the us is absolutely dragging its
fee and i think it's doing this because
of the dollar's position the dollar
right now is the world's reserve
currency on a good year before covert
inflation is just under two percent
which is pretty good compared to the
rest of the world and so we have to
understand that i mean you use the words
bitcoin does pose an existential threat
to the current system and so the us is
trying to figure out whether number one
bitcoin is a fad because if it is a fad
there's no point adopting it and
potentially risking the dollar's
position but the the reason they're
dragging their feet is because they're
trying to find out if it's not a fad
then we really need to get in on this
asap and so they don't want to be left
behind and i think we're getting to a
point where those at the top are
realizing that australia has its sport
etf canada has a sport etf and the us
really doesn't want to be left behind